oh this is not good oh
geez
that is shoulder to shoulder action
right there
what's up everybody this is jason bell
this is rate my skill
from sport bible oh man this is this is
this is what i like the
the future whoa what's going on here oh
oh oh geez oh my goodness
where did this kid come from
this is called keep your head on the
swivel you got to be aware out there
oh wow that's bringing the heat right
there i like that that kid's got a
future okay what do we got here
what did he just kick i don't even know
what just happened did he kick it
through that little post up there
this is amazing that is some serious
accuracy somebody needs to get this guy
a scholarship or something
these guys must be best friends because
you got to have some extreme confidence
in your buddy to allow him to do this
these guys are amazing
oh this one's harry kane harry's working
on his uh
nfl future and he's oh man harry got a
harry got a leg
and he's such a big dude like you know
he could kick run down there make some
tackles
i like what harry has to offer harry you
need an agent holler at me man we can
make this happen
they need you they want you star power
you got it let's make this happen oh
this is not good
oh geez
that is shoulder to shoulder action
right there oh wow look at the technique
though she led with the shoulder
oh no the girl tackling wasn't low
enough
you got to get lower oh this is my buddy
this is my buddy nate the great burleson
oh he's going to get his kid the
business oh this is this isn't going to
go well
oh oh oh yeah
this is what happens you see how the
kid's immediate reaction was to grab his
head
in panic that's what we do when we know
we just got shook
i don't think this kid knew who nate
burleson was but he found out real quick
what did he just do
it looks like somebody's uncle
he got tackled by the bush oh yeah
these guys oh we got the slow-mo too
oh this is great camera work oh wow
how's he gonna catch this
no he doesn't one hand it one hand catch
on vacation
and i guarantee you this guy had a beer
that being said this is amazing that is
so difficult
great skills it must be a college
athlete on spring break to get a
one-hand catch like that but that guy's
got
all it takes to be successful in the nfl
[Laughter]
you think they planned that but the one
guy wouldn't even get off his knees
i mean at least the other guy's in a
crouch position like he's ready to go
all right here we go we have the
england's cricket team
we got stuart braun at quarterback ben
stokes at receiver
oh very nice you see how he got
horizontal right there
but you know they know how to do that
because they're constantly catching
balls
all and weird angles and stuff like that
so i expect that kind of greatness
that's a good play right there
all right number three it's obviously on
the water on the skis we got to throw
from the boat in slow motion to my
man on the skis who comes down with it
with a
one hand catch you gotta give love
to anybody throwing the ball on vacation
on the water
amazing play number two is all about the
future
it's the kids of the next generation you
got him running why don't no he gets
knocked out
you love the kids of the future bringing
the
physical nature to the game number one
is all about skill and commitment and
it is my man with the field goal with
his buddy in the red hat
holding it with his chin you see
a great kicker and you see a great
holder
who is willing to put everything on the
line and what i mean
everything i mean all of his teeth that
is number one for me
those two guys get the gold
oh goal of the year call of the year
the person that scored the goal he had
the um
argument with the goalkeeper before the
game
oh that was a great own goal
not yet no yet i hope i won't